what we're going to do in this video is
discuss some of the foundational ideas
for the united states of america and we
could start at the most foundational of
ideas and that's the notion of
natural
rights
john locke one of the significant
enlightenment thinkers describes rights
like life
liberty and you might expect me to say
pursuit of happiness which is what we
see in the declaration of independence
but john locke refers to life liberty
and
property
but even though his version is a little
bit different than what ends up in the
declaration of independence most
historians believe that thomas jefferson
was heavily influenced by john locke's
idea of natural rights when jefferson
wrote the declaration of independence
and the idea here is that these are
rights that people should be born with
that should never be taken away from
them
and in the video on social contract we
talk about the idea of why someone would
form a government
they would form a government they would
give some rights to a government in
order to protect these basic rights
things like life liberty property the
pursuit of happiness and so you might
have some other rights that one would
say in a state of nature people might
have the right to
have do physical harm
on others
the right to imprison
others
the right to tax
others but in a social contract we
decide hey
instead of everyone trying to figure out
things on their own let's give these
rights to a
government
and in exchange the government should
protect
should protect all of these rights for
the individuals and once again this is
review from the social contract video
this is the notion of a social
contract
now the next question is all right so if
we are willing to engage in this social
contract with a government what type of
a government should it be and throughout
most of human history governments have
been things like
monarchies where you have a single
individual maybe a king or queen an
emperor some type of a conqueror who is
the sovereign who rules over the state
but you could have you could instead of
having one you could have a small group
which would be an oligarchy
or you could go to the other extreme
where the people are sovereign and the
word for that and this is a key idea for
the united states is popular
popular sovereignty the people are
sovereign
the government is accountable to the
people sometimes this could be referred
to as democracy
now the founding fathers of the united
states were a little bit suspicious of
pure
democracy or direct popular sovereignty
they were afraid that if you start
having factions and a majority faction
were to come to power if you have a
straight democracy then they might use
that power to strip some of the natural
rights of say their political enemies or
people that they just don't agree with
and so you have this other idea of
limited government
limited
government and some of the key
things that limit the government you
could just say generally the rule of law
things like the constitution
including how the government is
structured the checks and balances in it
the bill of rights
clearly is a check on government and you
don't just have limited government when
you have a democracy you could have a
limited government even in a monarchy
the united kingdom is officially a
constitutional monarchy where you have a
monarch whose sovereign has very limited
powers because of things like the rule
of law
now the last idea that we're going to
talk about in this video is the notion
of a republic or the idea of
republicanism
because the founding fathers
didn't actually like calling the united
states a democracy instead they favored
calling it a republic
and the word republic can mean different
things to different people today
depending on what context you use to
some folks today it means any form of
government that not that's not a
monarchy to other folks it means okay
you have a democracy you have popular
sovereignty but you have limited
government you still have rights that
protect minorities rights that make sure
that even if people are not in the
majority they are protected
to the founding fathers they had a
version of this notion of republic they
did view a republic as something that
would prevent the passions of an
unfettered pure democracy but they
thought it came mainly by having a
representative democracy that if you had
a smaller group of elected
representatives as opposed to everyone
getting involved in every issue that
they could calm the passions of the
crowds so to speak they also thought it
was logistically more practical sure
ancient athens could have something
closer to a pure democracy but that was
just a small city-state while here even
the 13 colonies were significantly more
vast and of obviously the united states
would become even more vast than that
and to appreciate this notion of a
republic
right over here is a quote from
james madison in the federalist papers
number 10. and just for some context on
what the federalist papers even were as
we mentioned shortly after the
declaration of independence the founding
fathers start drafting the articles of
confederation they go into effect in
1781 but this is really a loose
confederation of states that each
individually think of themselves as
sovereign states it's really a pact that
they'll engage in war together diplomacy
together free trade but you have shae's
rebellion and it's very clear and we'll
talk about this in other videos that the
articles of confederation are not
powerful enough and so you have a
constitutional convention in mid-1787
in which james madison is a central
figure some people discuss him as the
father of the us constitution
they draft what is today the
constitution but then they have to sell
it to the states in order for it to be
ratified alexander hamilton has the idea
of hey why don't we publish a series of
papers and they eventually publish 85
papers which will collectively be known
as the federalist papers and hamilton
writes most of them but he also recruits
james madison and john jay and
federalist papers number 10 which is
perhaps the most famous is james
madison's discussion of how do you avoid
factions taking over the government and
doing things that are not in the
interest of the people and i encourage
you to read all of federalist papers
number 10 but i have a very small quote
here and this is james madison's notion
of what a republic was and he thought
the united states should be republic the
two great points of difference between a
democracy and a republic are
first the delegation of government in
the latter so he's talking about a
republic to a small number of citizens
elected by the rest so he's really
talking about representative democracy
but he thought this was a key component
of being a republic
secondly the greater number of citizens
and greater sphere of country over which
the latter may be extended that only
through a representative government
could you actually govern over 13
colonies or even beyond 13 colonies and
that's why today obviously you might
have had something closer to a pure
democracy in ancient athens which was a
city-state but today almost any
democracy is some form of representative
democracy which james madison would
consider to be a republic but if you
wanted to classify the united states
today a fair term might be it is a
democratic republic you definitely have
popular sovereignty the people are
considered sovereign but they don't rule
directly they rule through
representatives which by madison's
definition would make it a republic so
now that you're armed with some of these
basic ideas i encourage you to engage
even more with some of the founding
documents for the united states and on
top of the declaration of independence
and the u.s constitution i encourage you
to read as many of the federalist papers
as possible because it's really an
explanation of the ideas behind the u.s
constitution and you should start with
federalist papers number 10. as you'll
see james madison is quite insightful he
predicts how factions might form how
parties might form and not always do
things in the interest of its people but
i'll leave you to decide whether he was
right whether forming a republic helps
this notion of factionalism and look at
the world that we are in today and think
about whether james madison would be
happy or maybe he would be a little bit
uncertain about how things turned out